by the way just does feel cool to stand
up there just feel good yeah yeah it
does I'm growing mad with power right
now et was invited on set of Star Trek
beyond we have your first look at what's
new on the enterprise well this is new I
haven't seen this before the the the
weapons base so this is kind of neat I
think those big phasers are brand new on
this one you'll notice that there's been
aging it's like we're two years into the
mission so this there's wear and tear on
the show tell me about what's new about
the uniforms I think it's a little it's
going back it's a little retro which I
really like
yeah it's it's just in the 50th
anniversary with you know the designers
have done a wonderful job of you know
giving a lovely nan to Star Trek
surpassed yes there's a baby on board
well sort of hi I want to break some
actual Star Trek news this is a secret
that everybody may not know about
explain this picture
Sulu has a baby pseudo has a better
better baby
at the beginning of the movie we're all
sort of getting into a we're all
homesick and we're getting into our ruts
and I think we've been around each other
too long and that's sort of where it
starts and sue Lewis has a heart ache
for his little baby and has brought his
picture to his console which technically
we've been saying it's it's
unprofessional it's in the way of the
buttons she's a cutie got it out of a
picture frame at Walgreens there isn't
another revelation that you'll find out
in regards to the into this baby but
then you'll have to wait to see the
movie
yep things were pretty secretive on set
especially when it came to getting eyes
on the script right good ready
scripts that have our names printed on
them there are specific spelling
mistakes incorporated into each draft so
if it were to get out they could still
track it back to whose script it was all
right time to head back to Los Angeles
um I have always wanted to do this beam
me up Scotty
you